Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Disney just
officially announced what’s going on with
the first Star Wars Episode 7 Trailer.
They’re going to attach it to special theater
showings this weekend.
So this video is going to be all about where
you can see, the best rumors about what’s
going to be in it and when they’ll post
it online.
Since I’m going to post a breakdown of it
Friday I think I’ll do a special Black Friday
giveaway.
Normally I give away one amazon gift card.
so let’s make it double.
two subscribers in the comments on this video
will be chosen.
So if you want to enter just make sure to
leave a comment and be a subscriber.
The earliest possible time you can see the
trailer will be Friday at one of the special
theaters at their earliest showing.
Any time Friday through Sunday.
Any showing of any movie at those theaters.
Although just to be safe I would go to a Disney
Movie.
But they said it’s all showings so you should
be fine.
There are 88 theaters and the trailer is 88
seconds long.
I guess there’s some significance in that
number.
But I’ve posted the full list of theaters
in the description below.
A lot of the theaters don’t have online
ticketing available so go to each of their
specific websites.
It’s AMC and Regal pretty much.
International People, The announcement didn’t
say anything about the UK or elsewhere but
the movie itself will premiere internationally
first before it premieres in the US.
So you can feel comforted by the fact you
can see it before any of us here get to see
it.
As for the trailer itself.
Because it’s 88 seconds long that means
it will have a bunch of footage from the actual
movie in it.
John Williams even recorded a special version
of the star wars theme for it.
We’ll see the main cast in full makeup including
the villains, some shots of the millenium
falcon that are supposed to be so awesome
they’ll feel like space porn.
And some jedi action.
The title of the movie is The Force Awakens,
so no matter what the rebellion and the empire
or any of the characters are doing in the
film.
You can think of it as a movie about The Force.
The originally trilogy was a movie about Luke’s
Redemption of Darth Vader.
The Force was just going on in the background.
This time based on the info we have, it seems
like the force itself is going to be the biggest
part of the plot.
That might change once they release episode
8 and 9.
The plot of the first star wars movie is really
all about Luke, but when you zoom out across
all six films.
You see it’s really about Anakin Skywalker.
I’m a really big fan of Disney turning the
trailer itself into a big event.
It feels appropriate since revitalizing the
Star Wars franchise is such a huge deal.
James Cameron went one step further when he
released the Avatar trailer.
He rented out theaters just so he could show
the trailer.
It wasn’t attached to films the first time
it premiered.
Tickets were free but he rented out IMAX theaters
for a special showing before the first trailer
posted online.
And if you’re old enough to remember, George
Lucas did the same thing with the Phantom
Menace trailer.
He showed it before a bunch of movies and
after.
So you got to see it twice.
Here’s a really cool article the New York
Times posted about it back in 1998.
Think about how long ago this was.
Here’s what they said about it:
''Star Wars'' is back.
Or more precisely, a 2 minute 10 second trailer
for ''Star Wars: Episode I -- The Phantom
Menace,'' the first ''Star Wars'' film since
the release of ''Return of the Jedi'' 15 years
ago.
The new film, written and directed by George
Lucas, opens on May 21, but the anticipation
for it is extraordinary, several distribution
executives say.
The trailer was screened on Tuesday in 26
states on 75 screens selected by the movie's
distributor, 20th Century Fox.
Fans heard about it four days earlier on the
Lucasfilm Web site (www.starwars.com), and
it quickly turned into a film event that had
no precedent.
Theaters showing films like ''The Waterboy,''
''The Siege'' and ''Meet Joe Black'' were
crammed with people -- mostly young men -- who
paid full admission just to see the trailer
and left when the movie began.
The trailer was also shown after each movie
ended, so a handful of theater owners allowed
filmgoers to return with their torn ticket
stub.
(Historically, trailers used to be shown after
movies ended, hence the name.)
Then here’s a quote from someone at Lucasfilm
at the time talking about the idea for doing
the special screenings
Tom Sherak, the chairman of Fox's Domestic
Film Group, said the idea for the early-in-the-week
trailer, which was released nationally over
the weekend, came from Mr. Lucas's associates.
''They said since they have such a big fan
base, why not set something up just for the
fans first and make sure it's shown to the
rest of the public very quickly?'' he said.
''The idea was to figure out a way to have
fun with this.
'Star Wars' is part of the culture, but it's
still a movie.
Let's treat it like a movie.''
That time around they only showed it in 30
theaters, so it wasn’t so much a box office
gimmick to boost ticket sales for that weekend.
I saw a lot of people talking about how doing
stuff like this is another way for Disney
to boost ticket sales for Big Hero 6 and Into
the Woods.
Two big tent pole movies it has in theaters
right now.
Here’s my big question for you, do you like
that they do big events for trailers like
this now?
I know everyone was expecting something special
for the Star Wars Celebration convention next
year and then on May 4th.
What they’ll probably do is release a full
trailer then at Celebration, then post it
online and then do another special event on
the 4th.
So they’ll still do new things and show
off new footage on those dates.
It’s just that they decided to take advantage
of the big Thanksgiving holiday and it’s
winter releases.
That’s another big reason it’s here now.
Star Wars used to be a Spring Franchise but
now all the movies are being released in the
winter.
So it’s a Winter event.
Again, don’t worry, they’ll post the teaser
trailer online by next week.
And yes, it will totally leak on the internet.
Someone somewhere will upload a crappy iphone
rip of the trailer.
So if you keep your eyes peeled you might
see it before it gets taken down.
Because it’s super illegal I can’t post
a rip of the trailer here on my channel till
Disney posts their official version online.
So I’m going to have to get a little creative
with the stuff I put in my breakdown video.
So if my breakdown looks a little weird, it’s
because Disney isn’t allowing footage to
be posted online till next week.
But I want to do a reaction video this friday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll post that X-Men Apocalypse video later
today.
Gotham tomorrow morning probably.
And if you haven’t seen me talk about it
yet.
Click here for my Star Wars Playlist and click
here for my X-Men Apocalypse video